PETER LUBBERS: Hi.
I'm Peter, and this is Jocelyn.
And we're with the Google
Developer Training Team
here at Google I/O in
our developer lounge.
And today we have some really
exciting announcements.
You probably heard
at the keynote Sundar
announce the Android Nanodegree.
But we also launched a
whole bunch of new courses.
Jocelyn, tell us a
little bit about that.
JOCELYN BECKER: Yes, Peter.
So we launched some
more Android courses.
We've launched a course
for complete beginners
to help you go from zero
programming to developing
an Android app.
We've also launched a course
for advanced Android development
and for Gradle.
And we actually have some
more courses coming out soon,
like I hope really, really soon.
We also launched
the first course
in our entrepreneur track.
So that's super exciting.
And why don't you tell us a
bit more about the Nanodegree?
PETER LUBBERS: Right.
So we're really
excited about a way
to tie all these
trainings together
into a more cohesive,
bigger story arc,
learning everything about
all the different aspects
of Android development.
And we do that
together with Udacity
in the form of this Nanodegree.
So the Nanodegree is
something you'd take
in addition to the courses.
For $200 a month,
you receive coaching,
you receive help from an
expert grading network,
and then you also
get a certificate
at the end that will hopefully
make you more employable.
To help with that
part, we also put
on a first-- what is called
the Android Career Summit.
Tell us a little bit about that.
JOCELYN BECKER: Yeah, so
the Android Career Summit
is where we're going to
invite 50 Android Nanodegree
graduates.
And that's actually
people who have either
graduated from the Nanodegree
or who are on track for it
to come to Google for an
all-expenses paid trip
to sunny California
to work together
and to work with
Google engineers
and to really get a practice at
what it's like to be an Android
developer.
We also have another exciting
initiative that perhaps you'll
tell us a bit more about.
PETER LUBBERS: OK.
Yeah, so the final
announcement we're making today
is that we teamed up with
the government of Egypt.
We want, of course,
the language barriers
not to be a problem
for training.
And so we teamed up with
the government of Egypt
to completely do an end-to-end
translation of all our training
into Arabic.
And we're also launching
2,000 scholarships
that we're giving away
to students in Egypt
to take an Android fundamentals
course in local language
coaching.
We're super excited about that,
and hopefully all these people
will get careers in
Android development.
So if you want to know more
about any of these initiatives,
go to udacity.com/google
and udacity.com/android
for the Android Nanodegree.
Thank you.